everybody thank you for having me first
of all so my first question for you is
the rhetorical question if you've ever
studied a language or you study the
region or something in a comparative
context or even a skill applied globally
how much better where that education
have been if you could interact with the
people the relevant country in a
sustained manner in an effective manner
we think the answer is a lot better and
so that's what we this will be dedicate
ourselves to and we're basically
starting a new organization which is
called to Lauren they contributes to
healthier global affairs by working with
institutional partners to make knowledge
trade and all its trade i think is our
buzz word between driven students
anywhere easy and effective what does
that mean we had our first pilot last
semester in fall we actually had two
case studies and what we did was we try
to have knowledge toward happen in the
medium of the dual country classroom two
countries meeting together and having
knowledge trade happen we started with
the hardest case first so we can prove
that this could work anywhere this is
Iraq this is American University of
Arkansas Dlamini and in the top UCL
students our first case course was
called reconstructing law after
political shock when you have a major
political transition how our legal
institution is reconstructed we had
three case studies South Africa Iraq and
Egypt we basically the basically the way
we thought it was first we would report
lectures like a MOOC massive online open
education course here's frustration
Shapiro Yale talking about South Africa
here's a professor in george w talking
about egypt we report the lectures you
put them online the students watch them
some professors who haven't had training
in giving a mono lecture or even if the
had training we decided that the
interview format was actually much more
interesting to have the interaction kind
of be captured on screen rather than
have have a monologue so we prefer the
interview format we reported we put
online the students in egypt watch it
the students in iraq watched it the
students that you washed it and then we
have them enter into a class like this
one in iraq or this one egypt and then
the students discuss the topic now
they've already had the lecture from the
professor they've already done the
readings the point
is for them to get knowledge they could
not have gotten in a mono country
classroom the classroom we have right
now and I think an example of that type
of knowledge trade is a is really well
represented in in hadiya's contribution
and then some of the back and forth they
had with the L so this is the American
University of Cairo hadeel happens to
also work in the Egyptian department of
economic progress she's the one that
deals with what happens to American a
when it goes to Egypt she knows what
happens to it and so we learned that and
we had a section on her Egypt case study
on the question what is the impact of
American aid on Egyptian legal
development or America or Egyptian legal
institutions and and we had draw the
greetings on it we had some of the
lecture focus on that but the but the
star of that conversation was obviously
the information ideal abroad and then
the old students had you know how to
fascinating back and forth what are the
American ethics of giving aid taking
back a word of the political
implications and it was a fascinating
discussion in contrast the Egyptian
students were very much interested in
American federalism and how in America
when we graduated into the West we had
it be territories first and when the
government was developed enough you had
States this was relevant for Egyptians
because they were wondering how do we
get the Sinai under control and this
federalism work and so we had some
fascinating discussions I mean in Iraq
we had conversations about American
perspective on the Iraq invasion the
rocky perspective on the Iraq invasion
these students are in the Kurdish region
so how does Kurdistan work with Iraq and
sometimes we sometimes we learned by
example there was a time in Egypt where
the students couldn't come to class
because of protests so we had them skype
in from their homes and when the
American government shutdown we had a we
had a joint commiseration session about
how what happens when your government
shuts down and we learned a lot about
comparative government shutdown it was
fascinating now we find that the
knowledge knowledge trade works
specifically in three
different types of courses one of them
is the comparative course we're trying
to compare something we're working with
a professor al to try to do a course
next semester in fall on comparative
perspectives in genocide where we bring
in the euro Steve Rwanda and maybe the
USSR I'm sorry DRC Sarajevo and if we
can get a hold of them the University of
Rwanda and there's many many more
possibilities for that the second thing
which we have an experimental with yet
but we do and I'd like to thank another
girl because I am also a lover of
languages but we want to start doing
language courses where we have the
knowledge trade happen as knowledge for
language so something we envision is the
group of advanced American Arabic
learners for example or whatever
language Spanish Chinese who can take a
course with native Arab speakers and
Arab speakers will be tasked with
helping the advanced speakers with
Arabic whereas the topic of the course
will be something that the American
students already know very well like
American history and then the Arabic
students get gets you know gets that
knowledge in return and the reason we
like knowledge trade is because this is
this is what makes it sustainable if
both countries benefit you can do it
because you both have a value-added if
it's more like an aid thing we're giving
knowledge it doesn't really last it
falls apart because only one person's
benefiting the third way that this works
is practical skills globally applied our
pilot for this semester which is
starting on Wednesday because there are
key academic calendars a bit different
is overcoming governance obstacles to
technology how to use technology to
overcome population management problems
and so we're looking at refugee camps
and hopefully we'll get students in Iraq
with level refugee camps and we we have
a it looks like it'll be a really cool
course is one example another example is
we even asked by a Syrian NGO to work
with american american engineering
universities to provide the knowledge of
engineering to syrian engineering
instructors and in return they'll be
able to do research there or they'll be
able to bring give us perspectives on
how do you rebuild a country a country's
infrastructure after war and so if
you're an American and you want to work
at the UN or you want to work in
international crisis group this is prime
training and if you're a Syrian and you
want to rebuild your country and you
want to run engineering this is
obviously a great way to do it because
hard to find teachers now I'm Syria so
so these are the three ways that we
think the dual country classroom and
always trade can work here's some
feedback from students from our first
semester the first semester we were
called global teaching self teaching
fellows here I give a thank you to Sarah
Ronis for representing the interests of
graduate students I happen to be
undergraduate student assembly on the
academic and professional development
committee and so one of my concerns
originally was also to make sure that
graduate students had a role in this and
so we have teaching fellows as well so I
used to be called global teaching
fellows but then everybody told me that
the name was really cheesy so we change
it to Lauren which I can explain later
but these are some do some feedbacks I
just think some some of the points here
are that this does not replace 30 abroad
but it's an extension of study abroad if
you study abroad and you come back to
America you can continue your
interaction if you never had the money
to study abroad this is also really good
and it's a way for you to do study
abroad as a group kind of and you can do
sustainably and it's very cheap that the
first two pilots cost $90 so so it's
really cheap to do here's the ears
feedback from one of the Egyptian
students and here's feedback from one of
the Yale students I don't want to talk
too much more I want to open for
questions so i can send people this is
they're interested we have a lot more we
have many more things like this
testimonials and stuff so what our goal
is now is we want to become a 501 C 3
and we want we want to grow this we want
to help universities being able to do
the dual country classroom we think of
it like the cell phone if you have one
cell phone it's useless it is if I have
a cell phone and Eric as a cell phone it
becomes a little bit more useful if I
was often or you'll have a cell phone it
becomes very useful and if I have a cell
phone in the whole world as a cell phone
this all phones very very very useful
our goal is to do what we call regional
gradualism work in regions starting with
the easiest universities then using our
alumni to spread into more difficult
places so for example I'll be going to
the Middle East in March and i'll be
using of e-commerce when conversing with
some of the alumni from the American use
your pyro and discussing how do we get
them to also get involved with maybe the
University of Cairo and other developing
Egyptian universities in in having those
partnerships be very useful similarly
the same thing in Iraq I should just met
with some
from the unity of Baghdad today and
we'll be working with how to we'll
figure out how to get that to work out
given our previous experience in Baghdad
but we want to get more cell phones out
there we want to get universities video
country classroom compatible so that no
matter where you are in the world you
can have a partnership with somebody
else and it's good for America is good
for American students is good for
European students is good for students
in developing countries and they
mutually benefit and you get horizontal
relationships it's not a top-down
zapping our knowledge to them we're both
trading and you know we want people to
get involved I i hardly ever bump
shoulders and anybody in the street now
except for that they get you know a good
two minutes from me about this but we
were recruiting a board of trustees we
have two down one more to go and we were
saving that spot for a Yalie we want
somebody from Yale this grew in Yale we
want somebody from Yale you know some so
we're looking for that person we're
looking for institutional partners we
want to require everybody here we're
looking for professor really focus
groups we often just meet with a
professor and we just say hey look
here's your idea what do you want to do
how you know what what if you could do a
dual country clubs from any country if
you could trade knowledge of anybody how
would you do it and we just talked with
them and we we work things out and we
also want to recruit one full-time
person in the summer right now our team
is basically two full timers on the side
we get our degree here at Yale but this
takes it just takes a lot of time we
have 44 find a part-time helpers here
ill then we have a team in Egypt and a
team in Iraq and we're trying to get a
team going in Bosnia for for one of the
classes and and here's your Ponte
information information mine is I'm Sode
Sode saaad dot I'm sorry ANS AR I yelled
Oh ed you Eric tilburg hey our ICT illb
ERG i yelled OED you will open the
questions we especially love critiques
whenever we get a new staff member I
have the old team critique me and like
to just like really rip my ideas apart
because we grow from critique and we
grow from criticism it's the best thing
in the world you know one of the best
things I guess after Yale and and
if that's welcome from anybody and if
anybody wants to brochure we have refers
to thank you questions our vision is
that refugee camps can become like Yale
University if you're in a refugee camp
you should be able to get a university
education questions I have a question
who's sponsoring sure who's helping you
with this we we have these other sort of
things that underpin things here at Yale
do you have a faculty sponsor up there
that to to oversee this or two to bounce
things off up from time to time or is
this initiative entirely student driven
so it was nothing student initiated um
we have a number of professors for whom
we're developing courses so for example
the Rwandan so I that the prospectus and
genocide course is a Yale professor
working with the senior fellow to get a
course going for next semester and I'm
going to be asking I'm going to be
asking another Yale professor to get
more involved soon it's really a
collection of people and in terms of
other sponsors we're developing or a
trustee so one of them is in New York
another one is in DC but we're building
a pool of people to help us out bill did
you have a question yeah thanks um not
to get too technical but nonetheless um
this concept is intriguing that it costs
ninety dollars to do a class like so can
you talk just a little bit of you know
what the technology was essentially and
how does one do this for $90 sure so
obviously that's everybody working pro
bono because we're all were all pilots
you mentioned that you know even for
this first summer program you guinea
pigs for I think like guinea heroes like
they go to like a lot of a lot of
development in the do it pro bono but
but the simplest version is we use just
just just like the just like the
language program we use we use the cisco
or web conferencing we do try google
hangout and skype because we actually do
have an intention to work with refugee
camps eventually good because students
refugee camps if you do the application
process
can be brilliant and we don't want them
to not have any opportunity so we Cisco
is expensive to use anil happens to have
it but other options the google hangout
is very cheap as a matter of fact we
consult with Google Google ideas from
time to time and we we figure out how to
how to make it better for our purposes
we are we're in discussion with the MOOC
platform the previous exists to see how
we can reattach the to make it better
fit for the dual country classroom for
resource sharing will be using canvas we
want to develop some technologies that
don't exist yet for example a bilingual
chat box it's not our goal now but it
struggled in two years to be able to
have a dual country classroom where the
students speak different languages it'll
take some pedagogical innovation and
detection technological innovation so we
want to develop a bilingual chat box but
that's two years down the road and other
than that we're always experimenting the
iPad idea sounds great so we'll probably
experiment without some time yeah we're
always experimenting other questions
critics are also welcome well once again
we learned that there are individuals
here at this institution doing wonderful
exciting things and and we can learn
from from this particular project to
project of Assad and Eric and more power
to you I guess how can we see this in
action is it possible for our committee
to to come in and sit in on the class at
some point so sorry be getting your new
semester on the rocky calendar on
Wednesday overcoming governance
obstacles technology so if you want to
sit in the same send me your Eric an
email and we'll have you come
everybody's welcome great wonderful
thank you so much
you